und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend das bundeskabinett hat den wunsch
beschlossen diese riesensumme geld die
der wirtschaft beine machen soll
dieses lustige wort booms hat olaf
scholz in umlauf gebracht sonst ist er
nicht sonderlich lustig ja auch nicht
das wort ist politik marketing und schon
deshalb mit vorsicht zu genießen
es klingt irgendwie gut gelaunt groß
mächtig zuverlässig unwiderstehlich in
wirklichkeit ist diese gewaltige
investition ein wagnis kalkuliertes
risiko wenn es gut geht wenn keine
weitere pandemiewelle das
wirtschaftsleben in die knie zwingt wenn
verbraucher verbrauchen und unternehmer
investieren
dann geht die wette auf wenn nicht dann
taumelt das land mit zusätzlichen 200
milliarden euro schulden auf dem buckel
in die nächste rezession
die politik hat ihre großen
entscheidungen getroffen jetzt kommt es
drauf an was 83 millionen menschen damit
anfangen in ihrem täglichen leben
bernd benthin berichtet schnell und mit
wucht gegen die krise
das ist das ziel deshalb heute kabinetts
sondersitzungen die wesentlichen teile
des konjunkturpakets werden
verabschiedet zentraler punkt die
senkung des mehrwertsteuersatzes von 19
auf 16 und des verminderten satzes von
sieben auf fünf prozent befristet bis
ende des jahres geschätzte kosten 20
milliarden euro
wir wollen ja eines erreichen dass sich
nämlich alle die ein bisschen unsicher
sind darüber wie es weitergeht jetzt an
scott p faxen und mut fassen oder
zumindest zuversicht und sagen ich
glaube ich nutze jetzt diese gelegenheit
auf gelegenheit nutzer hofft auch dieses
möbelhaus bei flensburg hier wollen sie
die drei prozent komplett an die kunden
weitergeben deklariert als sofort bonus
die korona zeit war hart fürs
unternehmen jetzt muss die kauflaune
steigen uns durchaus dass die menschen
investitionen die sie vorhaben auf jeden
fall umsetzen und dass sie sich
neuanschaffungen
möbel und einrichtung im allgemeinen
vielleicht leichter machen und jetzt im
nächsten halben jahr dann zu uns kommen
und ja wir erhoffen uns dass wir einen
kleinen schub bekommen weniger
mehrwertsteuer als konjunktur kobel
die deutschen sind da skeptisch laut
einer aktuellen umfrage des zdf
politbarometers glauben nur 13 prozent
dass die maßnahme der wirtschaft hilft
85 prozent glauben das nicht
kritik auch von der opposition bei den
produkten die täglich gebraucht werden
brot butter zeitungen dort wird es keine
senkung geben sie werden am ersten juli
die gleichen preise haben es ist ein
porsche rabatt und nicht etwa das
ankurbeln der nachfrage bei denjenigen
die in unserem land über weniger
einkommen und vermögen verfügen
ebenfalls beschlossen der kinderbonus
gekoppelt an das kindergeld kosten 4,3
milliarden euro
es ist eine einmalige zahlung in höhe
von 300 euro die in zwei raten gewährt
werden wird einmal im september zum
schulbeginn einmal im oktober zu den
herbstferien quasi keinen verwendet
werden zur freien verfügung die 300.000
sich vielleicht raus bist doch nicht zu
erwarten dass mit diesen 300 es den
familien jetzt wirklich besser geht oder
die wirtschaft davon einen sukzessiven
nachfrageschub hätte der sie gesunden
lisa größter einzelposten im paket 25
milliarden euro überbrückungshilfen für
unternehmen verbunden mit der hoffnung
dass das über das gröbste hinweghilft
wir stehen nach dem historischen
einbruch bei industrieproduktion und
exporte vor die notwendigkeit die
überlebensfähigkeit und die
durchhaltefähigkeit unserer vitalen
wirtschaft und industrie strukturen zu
sichern wenn das konjunkturpaket nicht
wirkt dann ist deutschland gleich
doppelt betroffen dann werden wir
doppelt verlieren
zum einen wird der schuldenberg wachsen
und zum anderen droht dass die zahl der
arbeitslosen im kommenden jahr wachsen
wird
im eiltempo soll das paket jetzt durch
bundestag und bundesrat eine
milliardenschwere wette auf wachstum
der krise die zahlen des politbarometers
die am ende der sendung stehen werden
werden zeigen dass die deutschen mit
erheblichen mehrheiten sehr für dieses
konjunkturpaket sind im großen ganzen
wenn es dann aber an die einzelheiten
geht dann ist auch der eine oder andere
mit der einen oder anderen regelung und
zufrieden das drückt alles im grunde
erwartungen aus was sagen die
erfahrungen
das deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung
dessen chef präsident der professor
marcel vater ist hat dieses
konjunkturpaket durchleuchtet und
nachgerechnet guten abend nach berlin
professor vater genannt der kleber
fangen wir mal ganz praktisch an wenn da
eine familie ist die sich entschlossen
hat mal 1000 euro in die wohnzimmer
einrichtungen zu investieren
dann bringt dieses tolle konjunkturpaket
ihnen auf die 1000 euro 30 euro rabatt
das soll was auslösen wird das nicht
versanden
es wird das auslösen es wird vielen
familien helfen und wir haben berechnet
dass eine familie mit mittlerem
einkommen mit 400.000 euro
monatseinkommen
ungefähr im durchschnitt 80 euro im
monat sparen wird durch die
mehrwertsteuerabsenkung also es ist
jetzt kein riesiger betrag aber für
viele macht es sehr wohl einen
unterschied
allerdings muss man auch gleichzeitig
sagen das hängt natürlich davon ab dass
die unternehmen die geschäfte diese
senkung wirklich weitergeben an die
konsumenten und zweitens dass die
konsumenten auch ihr verhalten nicht
verändern also dass sie weiterhin
konsumieren und das sind natürlich zwei
wichtige bedingungen nicht alle
unternehmen werden es weiter geben
nicht alle konsumenten werden weiterhin
zu konsumieren aber trotzdem das ist
eine größenordnung 80 euro das ist jetzt
keine riesige summe aber es hilft den
familien schauen gerade die natürlich
wenig einkommen haben wenn wir mal das
ganz große bild dieses riesenpaket es
sich anguckt was erwarten sie sich an
effekten auf die wirtschaft es wird ja
ungefähr 10 prozent runter gehen haben
sie gesagt oder errechnet was wäre es
denn ohne das paket
ja wir gehen davon aus dass die deutsche
wirtschaft in diesem jahr um zehn
prozent schrumpft und dass dieses
konjunkturpaket alleine die
wirtschaftsleistung um ungefähr 1,5
prozent stützt
das heißt also meine einer chance und
zehn prozent wegen 1,5 prozent
unterschied diese riesigen beträge
auszunehmen
naja ich denke das ist mit man muss
überlegen was heißt es ganz konkret das
sind ungefähr haben wir auch errechnet
ungefähr 700.000 arbeitsplätze die ein
solches konjunkturpaket jetzt und in der
zukunft schützt also
arbeitsplatzverluste die sonst die
diesen stattfinden würden und das sind
700.000 menschen sieht man 1000 familien
die davon profitieren
und ja da kann man natürlich schon
drüber argumentieren aber das ist jetzt
keine geringe geringe anzahl ist denn
die gefahr damit weg dass die wirtschaft
doch noch irgendwann auf der strecke sei
es mit einer zweiten pandemiewelle oder
ohne zusammenbricht und am ende die
bundesrepublik mit nochmal 200
milliarden schulden mehr in die nächste
krise taumelt das ist in der tat liegt
das große risiko
ich denke wir unterschätzen dass vieles
schief gehen kann wie zweite welle der
pandemie die sie ansprechen
wir haben aber auch weltweiten sehr
schwachen globalen handel die deutschen
exporte sind eingebrochen und unsere
volkswirtschaft hängt sehr stark davon
ab wir wissen nicht ob eine finanzkrise
auch das resultat einer einer solchen
pandemie sein könnte wenn unternehmen
und banken in schieflage kommen
wir wissen nicht wie es in anderen
europäischen ländern weiter geht also
die risiken sind enorm
aber ich glaube man muss schon abwägen
wenn man nichts tut wenn die
bundesregierung ihnen das geld nicht
ausgeht dann sehen wir eine große
verlust von arbeitsplätzen und auch
insolvenzen bei unternehmen und je
größer dieser schaden jetzt ist desto
permanente also wenn unternehmen pleite
sind dann entstehen die ja nicht sofort
im nächsten jahr neu wenn menschen
arbeitslos sind dann brauchen sie auch
einige jahre wieder arbeit zu finden
also jetzt diesen schaden zu begrenzen
halte ich aus einer
wirtschaftspolitischen sicht für wichtig
weil es letztlich dann auch eine
schnellere erholung wieder möglich macht
und das ist glaube ich das wichtige bei
einem solchen paket das heißt es bleibt
spannend in den nächsten sechs monaten
aber die wette ist jetzt sozusagen
gemacht und gilt dankeschön professor
vater sehr gerne bleiben wir bei
gewagten große investitionen vor einem
jahr haben die großen
telekommunikationsunternehmen in
deutschland sechseinhalb milliarden euro
für 5 g frequenzen im
bildung investiert es soll der sprung in
eine superschnelle daten zukunft sein
schlüsseltechnologie des 21 jahrhunderts
aber offenbar wird nur die zukunft
schnell die gegenwart ist es weniger es
wenn ricken ist unser fachmann versuches
christian jost hat mühe das neue 5g netz
mitten in hamburg zu finden angeblich
ist die city schon fast flächendeckend
vernetzt in der praxis aber hat er nur
zwei standorte gefunden an denen 5 g
punkt und das ist jetzt wirklich so ein
bisschen millimeterarbeit gewesen also
zwei meter weiter hatte ich dann wieder
4g
ja es ist so der fortschritt kommt
sozusagen in kleinen schieben
die meisten oberklasse handys
unterstützen den neuen mobilfunkstandard
seit rund einem jahr
wie schnell das neue netz zumindest im
hamburger hauptbahnhof ist zeigt das
handy an
2 150 megabit pro sekunde
damit könnte man das komplette
heute-journal von gestern in 14 sekunden
herunterladen
mit den bisher schnellsten standard lte
würde das schon eine minute 28 dauern
ein durchschnittlicher dsl-anschluss
bräuchte drei minuten und 50 sekunden 5g
ist also schnell und kann viele
handynutzer gleichzeitig bedienen
vor ein zwei jahren die leute angefangen
einfach ganz standardmäßig immer videos
abzuspielen auf die ganzen internet
dienste sind eher auf mobile nutzung
optimiert und das ist natürlich etwas wo
enorme ressourcen gebraucht werden nur
mit 5 g kriegen wir das auf dauer hin
6,5 milliarden euro haben die vier
telekommunikationsunternehmen bei der
versteigerung der 5g lizenzen vor einem
jahr zahlen müssen
erstmals bekamen sie dabei auflagen für
die netzausbau bis ende 2022 sollen 98
prozent aller deutschen haushalte die
hohe geschwindigkeit nutzen können davon
sind die telekommunikationsanbieter
allerdings noch weit entfernt
das schwierigste am ausbau sind nachher
die letzten dreißig die letzten 20
prozent da wird es dann noch mal darauf
ankommen dass man hier auch in den
schwer zu erschließenden gebieten die
glasfaserleitung noch bis zu den masten
bekommt das wird dann noch eine noch
größere herausforderung
erstmals sind mit fünf gehen einem
mobilfunknetz kleine unter netze möglich
im hamburger hafen etwa testete die
telekom die vernetzung von hunderten
ampeln mit lkw und schiffen wird ein
container riese entladen haben die lkw
grün in solchen anwendungen schlummert
das 5g potenzial die ja hauptnutzen
liegt ganz klar auf der industriellen
seite
da gibt es ganz neue möglichkeiten
echtzeitanwendungen kontrollen
funktionen von maschinen kontrollen über
maschinen das wird eine neue welt noch
etwas kann 5g kommunikation
untereinander autonom fahrenden
schlepper können direkt mit dem schiff
interagieren der nutzer auf der brücke
kann die schiffe sogar fernsteuern klar
zukunftsmusik aber technisch machbar
erst mal aber muss das netz wachsen dann
muss auch christian jost nicht mehr auf
5 gesuche gehen
wir werden sie nachrichten von gundula
gause
bundeskanzlerin merkel ist offen für
eine debatte über ein mögliches
streichen des begriffs rasse im
grundgesetz vor dem hintergrund der
weltweiten anti rassismus
demonstrationen fordern verbände und
politiker darunter justizministerin
lambrecht einen ersatz des begriffs
rasse beim gleichheitsgebot die grünen
schlagen zum beispiel vor zu formulieren
niemand dürfe wegen seines geschlechts
seiner abstammung oder seiner herkunft
rassistisch benachteiligt oder bevorzugt
werden
die gefahr durch das corona virus in
europa ist nach einschätzung der
eu-kommission noch nicht vorbei die
regierungen müssten weiterhin auf tests
und kontrolle setzen sagte
gesundheitskommissarin kreatives in
einer video-konferenz mit den eu
gesundheitsminister
positiv reagierten die minister auf die
pläne der eu für eine gemeinsame
impfstoff strategie um so schnell wie
möglich an die benötigten mittel zu
kommen
nach thüringen lockert auch brandenburg
die krone regeln drastisch ab montag
fallen die kontakt beschränkungen weg
abstands und hygieneregeln aber bleiben
das könnte ich die ministerpräsident
wollte an
demnach dürfen in brandenburg auch
wieder veranstaltungen mit bis zu 1000
menschen stattfinden
dazu zählen auch gottesdienste und
konzerte in den ostdeutschen
bundesländern sind die infektionszahlen
vergleichsweise niedrig in den usa
wächst die sorge vor einer neuen
infektionswelle
es gibt dort bereits mehr als zwei
millionen corona fälle und die zahlen
steigen aktuell wieder deutlich
besonders betroffen ist arizona
krankenhäuser kommen an ihre grenzen
wegen eines starken anstiegs der neuen
fälle in der vergangenen woche in
insgesamt 21 bundesstaaten gibt es
deutlich mehr neuinfektionen in arkansas
und utah bis zu 60 prozent
experten und behörden der betroffenen us
staaten warnen dass corona wiro sei dort
noch nicht unter kontrolle
eine zweite welle der korona pandemie
ist für viele länder das schreckgespenst
schlechthin
die ungewissheit ob sie kommt ist schwer
auszuhalten
in iran ist diese zweite welle schon da
iran ist ein stolzes entwickeltes land
mit erstklassiger medizin nicht überall
im land aber sie prägt die standards und
die erwartung iran ist gleichzeitig ein
land das wirtschaftlich am boden liegt
die last der vor allem amerikanischen
sanktionen sind kaum auszuhalten
sollte es jemals eine impfung oder
medikamente geben iran könnte die
rechnungen dafür wegen des
us-finanzinvestors bezahlen wenn das
geld hätte die mullahs sehen da eine
chance die schuld an der misere an allem
was schiefläuft inland den usa sprich
donald trump in die schuhe zu schieben
unser iran korrespondent jörg brase
berichtet die iranische presse verfolgt
genau was sich da gerade beim erzfeind
tut die us regierung unter dem druck der
strasse proteste gegen rassismus und ein
hilfloser präsident nur zu gern nutzt
dass die iranische führung für die
eigene propaganda
revolutionsführer ayatollah khamenei
jetzt richtung amerika den ewigen feind
er sein land mit sanktionen versucht in
die knie zwingen der grund für die
unruhen die wir in den städten und
bundesstaaten der usa sehen ist dass
dort die wahrheit immer unterdrückt
wurde
es ist wie der stinkenden schlamm am
boden eines sees der jetzt an die
oberfläche kommen
für vw haschemi klingen hamas worte wie
hohn und sie sagt das auch laut und
deutlich
die streitbare tochter von ex präsident
rafsandschani ist wütend
schauen wir doch mal auf unsere eigene
bilanz proteste im november vergangen
proteste im jahr 2017 und 2009
dazwischen etliche unruhen und bei uns
ist man damit viel schlimmer umgegangen
es gab unzählige verhaftungen und nach
offiziellen angaben 230 tote in nur zwei
tagen die kritik an den usa ist ein
bitterer scherz
was sich auf den straßen im ganzen land
im november vergangenen jahres abspielte
war eine tragödie
die polizei schießt auf die wütende
menge
es herrscht chaos ausgelöst durch die
erhöhung der benzinpreise
es war der tropfen der das fass zum
überlaufen brachte ein volk das unter
den wirtschaftssanktionen leidet
demonstriert gegen seine führung diese
führung aber meint der journalist
hossein abdullahi behauptet stets jeder
protest sei von amerikanischen agenten
gesteuert die kluft zwischen staat und
volk in iran ist nicht zu verleugnen
es ist mittlerweile so weit gekommen
dass selbst funktionsträger zu geben wie
sehr das vertrauen der bevölkerung
gesunken ist wie sehr das regime an
legitimität verloren hat und das lässt
sich an der wahlbeteiligung und anderen
statistik noch gut ablesen
so gingen in der hauptstadt teheran bei
der parlamentswahl im februar nur noch
27 prozent der wähler zu den urnen die
kritik der führung an den usa
interessiert die meisten hier nicht da
protestieren andere leute auf der
anderen seite der welt in einem anderen
land was geht uns das an
kümmert euch um unsere eigene miserable
lage die iranischen jugend ist
arbeitslos die korona pandemie hat die
lage der menschen in iran zusätzlich
verschärft und ihre führung tut was sie
immer tut sie sucht die schuld bei den
anderen die börsen mussten zu diesem
wochenschluss den gestrigen kursrutsch
verkraften
der dax gab den fünften tag in folge
nach finanz experten sind sich uneinig
wann und wie schnell sich die wirtschaft
nach der pandemie erholen kann frank
bethmann
wie sieht man das auf dem frankfurter
börsenparkett na ja auf einmal drängt
sich der eindruck auf das könnte doch
alles viel länger dauern mit der
erholung und das hier ist die längst
überfällige kurskorrektur an den börsen
wo man ja schon dachte sind die denn
irre galoppierende kurse trotz
historische krise das aber mit der
kurskorrektur könnte ein irrtum sein
denn die finanzmärkte werden auch
weiterhin von dem profitieren was
eigentlich für die arg gebeutelte
weltwirtschaft gedacht ist von diesen
riesen
oder konjunkturprogramm an deren spitze
vier institutionen stehen die keinen
zweifel daran lassen dass sie ihre
bisher in aussicht gestellten
billionensummen auch noch erhöhen wenn
nötig und damit das nicht wirkt wie ein
leeres versprechen macht der
us-finanzminister in einem interview
kommt ernst es solle im nächsten monat
eine weitere billion dollar in die
weltgrößte volkswirtschaft gepumpt
werden
nicht immer aber passt die formel viel
geld hilft auch viel anders sind die
größer werdenden zweifel an einer
schnellen erholung der weltwirtschaft
nicht zu erklären
eines aber dürfte sicher sein solange
die finanzmärkte diese signale bekommen
es ist unendlich viel geld vorhanden so
lange werden sich die börsen weiter
abkoppeln von leeren geschäften
geschlossenen fabriken und millionen
arbeitslosen oder menschen in kurzarbeit
vielen dank frank in der folge der
korona pandemie könnten weltweit
millionen junge menschen neu in
kinderarbeit gedrängt werden davor
warnen un-organisationen am
internationalen tag gegen kinderarbeit
weltweit müssten noch immer 152
millionen mädchen und jungen im alter
von fünf bis 17 jahren arbeiten die
bundesregierung kündigte an den kampf
gegen kinderarbeit zu einem schwerpunkt
der deutschen eu ratspräsidentschaft zu
machen
heute wäre anne frank 91 jahre alt
geworden das jüdische mädchen starb im
alter von 15 jahren im
konzentrationslager bergen belsen
alljährlich engagieren sich an diesem
tag bundesweit zehntausende schüler
gegen judenhass ergebnis vielfältiger
auseinandersetzung mit dem holocaust
schirmherrin bundesjustizministerin
lambrecht sagte anne franks geschichte
zeige was passieren könne wenn man nicht
auf stunde und sich engagieren
gegen antisemitismus und
menschenfeindlich
an dieser stelle berichten wir oft über
erstaunliche neue entwicklungen heute
über eine ganz besondere sie löst ein
scheinbar unlösbares problem
moko matt habe eine hinreißende junge
pianistin in tokio muss vorspielen für
einen studienplatz an der
musikhochschule freiburg fast 10.000
flug kilometer entfernt aber fliegen es
nicht in pandemie zeiten
schade wäre da nicht eine technik die
moko watabe in freiburg klavier spielen
lässt von tokio aus in perfekter
wiedergabe hightech musikalisch und
sinnlich eine perfekte übertragung live
die ideale lösung bis die nasa endlich
das wie mannschaft im raumschiff
enterprise schon lange grundausstattung
aber es geht auch ohne
scotty es wenn glas gericht
es ist als beobachter schon etwas
verwirrend wenn die tasten eines
klaviers plötzlich beginnen sich zu
bewegen und wird noch faszinierender
wenn der kopf erfasst das fast
zehntausend kilometer entfernt in tokio
live gespielt wird was dann in freiburg
ein klavier steuert
eine neue prüfungssituation für jury und
bewerberin heute war aufseher aufgelegt
weil ein fernseher steht nebenbei direkt
bei mir und das gedicht und protest ganz
große seit fast 20 jahren spielt moko
watabe klavier ihr ziel jetzt einer der
wenigen plätze im konzertexamen
studiengang international extrem begehrt
[Musik]
eigentlich wollte sie dafür persönlich
in deutschland vor spielen kann wie
viele andere derzeit aber nicht ohne
weiteres an reisen die bewerber können
deshalb ausnahmsweise eigene videos
einsenden oder eben per fern prüfung
bewertet werden war für uns denke ich
alle aus der kommission frappant wie
echt wie echt live es wirkt weil wir
einen authentischen analogen klang haben
also dieser echtheits charakter ist
erstaunlich aussagekräftiger als eine
einfache videoaufnahme denn die technik
erfasst jede tasten berührung ganz
sensibel und präzise die stärke jedes
anschlags in über 1.000 abstufungen
transportiert sie vom einen flügel zum
anderen setzt ihn in bewegung
die technik nicht ganz neu die hochschul
eignungsprüfung mit diesem klavier eine
weltpremiere
[Musik]
wir haben gedacht jetzt ist der moment
um das zu machen klar und haben es
ausprobiert und das was hier entwickelt
worden ist glaube ich nicht nur ein
modell für diese hochschule sondern
vielleicht auch ein modell für andere
hochschulen auch wenn prüfungszeit ting
und raumklang für den prüfling anders
sind technik rhythmik und klangfarbe des
werks kommen an wichtige
bewertungskriterien wie auch die eigene
interpretation eines stücks klavier zu
spielen bedeutet in sich hinein zu
schauen das klavier ist etwas das den
pianisten die pianistin als person
widerspiegelt für den herbst planen sie
die letzte runde im bewerbungsverfahren
tomoko watabe will dabei sein dann aber
am liebsten vor ort in freiburg
[Musik]
es müssten nicht gerne ob sie
aufgenommen wurde ich hoffe es her ein
schönes detail diese technik kommt aus
japan zurück nach freiburg vor über 100
jahren hat ein michael welte in freiburg
ein verfahren patentiert dass das spiel
eines pianisten auf loch papierrollen
aufgezeichnet hat und wieder geben eine
weltsensation der bis sieben maler
richard strauss haben sich darauf
verewigt bevor es brauchbare
schallplatten gab eine deutsche
erfindung also in japan vollendet es ist
bei weitem nicht die einzige das war es
vom journal bis morgen nun wie
versprochen die aktuellen zahlen zur
politischen gemütsverfassung in
deutschland guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer mit wumms will die
bundesregierung die größte
wirtschaftliche krise der
nachkriegsgeschichte überwinden
kaufprämien kinder boni entlastung der
kommunen sie hat ein konjunkturpaket
geschnürt und rekordsummen in die hand
genommen
130 milliarden euro als antwort auf die
korona krise und die folgen und wie
finden dass die deutschen mehr als zwei
drittel halten das konjunkturpaket alles
in allem für gut
nur 22 prozent sehen das anders jeder
zweite findet den umfang der maßnahmen
genau richtig für 17 prozent sind die
130 milliarden euro zu viel geld für 14
prozent zu wenig eine insgesamt hohe
zustimmung zum konjunkturpaket also die
quer durch alle politischen lager geht
auch die tatsache dass deutschland jetzt
hohe schulden aufnimmt um die wirtschaft
zu beleben finden drei viertel aller
befragten richtig nur bei den anhängern
der afd sieht man das mehrheitlich
kritisch
ein herzstück des konjunkturpakets aber
ruft bei den allermeisten deutschen
zweifel hervor
nur 13 prozent erwarten dass die senkung
der mehrwertsteuer helfen wird die
wirtschaft stark anzukurbeln
85% aber glauben das nicht
auch die erhöhte kaufprämie für
elektroautos wird mehrheitlich abgelehnt
44 prozent finden sie gut 52 prozent
nicht die große koalition hat in der
krise nach dem motto nicht kleckern
sondern klotzen gehandelt und will so
für stabilität und zuversicht sorgen
davon profitiert weiter vor allem die
union in der projektion gibt es derzeit
wenig veränderung
wenn schon am nächsten sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre könnten cdu/csu mit
39 prozent rechnen
die spd 15 die afg 9 die fdp vier
prozent alle unverändert die linke käme
auf 7 minus 1 die grünen könnten leicht
zulegen 20 prozent plus 1 damit gäbe es
weiter eine mehrheit für schwarz grün
und schwarz rot große konstanz auch bei
den köpfen hier unsere top ten der
wichtigsten politiker nach sympathie und
leistung auf der skala von +5 bis -5 auf
platz 10 christian lindner minus 0,3
davor horst seehofer 0,6 beide
unverändert
dann armin laschet 0,6 etwas besser
robert habeck 1,0 unverändert auf platz
sechs peter altmaier 1,1 leicht
verschlechtert davor jens spahn 1,3
leicht verbessert aufgerückt off platz
vier hubertus heil 1,3 etwas besser auf
dem dritten platz
olaf scholz 1,8 und verändert wann 2 für
markus söder 1,9 leicht verschlechtert
weiter an der spitze angela merkel 2,5
und verändert die gefahr durch das
corona virus ist weiter präsent doch die
menschen in deutschland sorgen sich
jetzt weniger um ihre gesundheit als in
den letzten wochen und monaten
inzwischen fühlen sich 60 prozent nicht
gefährdet durch das virus
gleichzeitig ist fast ein drittel der
bevölkerung weiter vorsichtig und findet
die lockerungen der korona maßnahmen
gehen schon zu weit
risiko oder notwendigkeit was halten die
deutschen vom thema kita und schule
öffnung die mehrheit 52 prozent spricht
sich dafür aus den betrieb schnell und
vollständig wieder aufzunehmen
42 prozent sind dagegen und 6 prozent
wissen es nicht zu einem ganz anderen
thema schauen wir in die usa
der gewaltsame tod von george floyd hat
weltweit menschen bewegt präsident trump
steht in der kritik die überlegungen der
usa einen teil ihrer truppen aus
deutschland abzuziehen belasten das
deutsch amerikanische verhältnis
zusätzlich neun von zehn deutschen sagen
die usa unter trump sind kein
verlässlicher partner für die sicherheit
in europa und über die hälfte der
deutschen 56 prozent glaubt nicht dass
donald trump bei der
präsidentschaftswahl im november
wiedergewählt wird
zurück nach europa wo die grenzen für
reisende wieder geöffnet werden
doch in zeiten von corona löst das nicht
nur erleichterung aus 43 prozent freuen
sich über offene grenzen in der eu und
in europa aber 52 prozent bereitet das
eher sorgen dass genau diese lockerung
zu einem anstieg der infektionszahlen
führen könnte
der wunsch nach sicherheit ist also groß
helfen könnte dabei die geplante corona
app mit der infektionsherde erkannt und
eingedämmt werden sollen
die akzeptanz dafür ist seit april aber
gesunken
eine mehrheit will diese app nicht
nutzen das war unser bericht über die
stimmung im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und auf zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer von
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es dann am
26 juni und nach dem wetter übernimmt
gleich die heute show mit oliver welke
ihnen noch einen entspannten abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schon genannte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wie popcorn in der
pfanne schießen die wolken in die höhe
das sind hier diese gewitter die
ziemlich extrem waren gestern und diese
luftmasse die erreicht uns allmählich
und so wird es morgen ebenfalls zu
extremen gewittern kommen
schauen wir erstmal in die nacht und
über die nacht hinweg gibt es hier
gewitter nach nordosten denn die können
schon stark regen mitbringen und hier
sinkt die temperatur gerade mal auf 18
grad im westen ebenfalls schauer und
gewitter die am rhein entlang ziehen und
ganz im süden die temperatur bei neun
grad morgen im rot schraffierten bereich
geht es zur sache
teils mit 30 40 50 liter auf den
quadratmeter
die wären durch die gewitter erzeugt
dieser langsam ziehen
hagel und sturmböen sind inklusive aber
auch hier in diesem gelb schraffierten
bereich müssen sie mit gewittern rechnen
zum abend hin dann im südwesten kräftige
gewitter dort wo wir keine strafe haben
da kann es auch mal blitzen und donnern
die temperaturen steigen dazu bis auf 31
grad im osten deutschlands generell ist
diese luftmasse ziemlich schwül und
drückend am angenehmsten vielleicht noch
gerade an der ostsee mit 20 grad
die nacht auf sonntag die bringt weitere
kräftige gewitter einmal quer über
deutschland ebenfalls mit den üblichen
verdächtigen starkregen hagel und
sturmböen
nach osten hin da lockt hat es schon
wieder auf 4 20 grad als dies wert im 7
12 grad und am sonntag einmal vom
emsland bis diensten in den bayerischen
wald kräftige gewitter aber auch im gelb
schraffierten bereich ebenfalls heftige
gewitter und das bei temperaturen bis 27
grad im osten aber nach süden er 16 grad
damit ein schöner abend